herzlich zu einer neuen folge ich fahre
leute ich bin heute in meiner
heimatstadt köln und heute gibt es eine
ganz besondere folge denn ich werde zum
ersten mal nicht ein auto oder ein
motorrad von einem agenten erfahren und
wenn ihr mir folgt dann seht ihr hier
eine wunderschöne husqvarna supermoto
701 und irgendwie helfen
[Musik]
ja man richtig geil dass es geklappt hat
ich bin richtig richtig richtig heiß auf
das erste motorrad können in kleinen
geschenk machen da sieht er ganz viele
sachen herumliegen verhältnis steht
meine heißt alex wird jetzt gleich dann
meine fahren wir übersehen das
miteinander reden unsere eindrücke
austauschen können und ja was haben wir
hier wenn ihr mal hier um kunst und
jemand runter schaut seht ihr hier ein
krümmer das heißt es ein einzylinder ja
richtig man sieht doch eigentlich
installieren da relativ gut hier nach da
vorne und ist seit gerät 700 comic knapp
glaubt etwas darunter ich weiß nicht wer
unsere 701 und 74 ps aus einem einzigen
zylinder der die jetzt noch das noch die
euro 3 216 er war es glaube ich die ist
die letzte die noch 69 grad und deswegen
auf eur 3 es heißt jedoch ein bisschen
lauter sein anderer schadstoffklasse
okay die soll ein bisschen mehr wumms
nach unten raus haben aber dafür ein
bisschen weniger oben rausfahren sich
muss man sagen ein zylinder im motorrad
ist ja schon krank in der regel sind die
einzelnen dazu nicht wartungs aufwendig
ist gefühlt nach einer fahrt wieder
komplett auseinanderbauen und bei den ja
bei der 76 90 umwelt 701 die sind
eigentlich ziemlich entspannt die
vibrieren auch nicht mehr ganz so krass
wie früher die noch dient also schon
wieder noch so ein bisschen das tier
gleich merken ja die ganz neuen weg sei
eigentlich das gefühl unterschied mehr
zu 14 ländern unsere aber da werde ein
bisschen länger bis die so richtig
leicht auch bei 145 149 oder in die
trockenen 50 kilo leichter einfach als
meine maschine und das ist richtig über
den bikes ja du bist in rom offiziell
machen sich immer lustig hatte hier oben
so franz so weil sie noch in köln war
jetzt mir jetzt umgezogen ist noch
sämtliche jetzt wenn ich bald wieder ein
bisschen mehr liebe ins motorrad
einstecken ja aber so könne nicht
irgendwie nicht die ruhe alle machen
sich auch über diese schrauben lustig
ist ein fetter kopf ist ja die erste
schraube die ich gefunden habe diese
post ansätze ich wäre das alles noch
austauschen egal ist doch schön also das
kenne ich von von dave sxc lächerlich
ist dieses mini display ist ein paar
taschen reichen anlegen
jetzt irgendwie so 7 halbzeit neue
kosten die über 10 und darfst du so ein
display einfach es ist krass das ist
also meine dahinten leute für 91
bekommen braucht kosten 10 halten das
ist bestimmt eine tankanzeige oder jack
lang ja man sitzt auf den punk drauf
geil hier sieht man du hast auch eine
after market anlage schon drauf ja genau
die habe ich direkt als erstes drauf
gemacht weil der haushalt gar nicht also
wirklich überhaupt nicht hübsch ist und
sich auch noch gar nix an hört ja soll
ich noch gar nichts gar nichts was ganz
cooles bei diesen einzelnen generell bei
den supermotos wenn du so nicht groß auf
dem gas bis sind ja auch gar nicht laut
aber wenn du so ein bisschen untertourig
mal vollgas richtig knallen halt dann
richtig und gerade wenn nun im tunnel
bis zu dieser kontrast von standgas und
langsam fahren bis zur knallvoll durch
es halt ganz woanders dann wieder
deswegen erschrecken sich immer alle
voll wir direct x 11 stück machen ja
ganz okay war echt aus maschine ja man
könnte jetzt sagen deshalb cool weil es
ihrem oft kommt aber ich bin halt für
den preis unserer schule frech
eigentlich 515 er kann man schon
eigentlich ja wirtschaft will war kosten
mittlerweile sogar glaubt die neue
leichen 1 eigentor krank alter ja das
ist ja wie ein fahrrad ja doch so leicht
so dass sattelfesten schmal und
irgendwie ein bisschen hart aber auch na
ja auf jeden fall ich komme irgendwie
besser mit diesen harten als mit den
weichen nach der ganganzeige legale
handel auf anzeige
naja also man sieht ja noch okay wir
sind im leerlauf kilian hier ne richtig
und kupplung ziehen aber ist der lauf
trotzdem ist der lauftrainer muss nach
dem produktionsstart auch du nicht nein
das ist ja ist ohne kohl und südstaaten
ja klar im leerlauf durch das heißt es
geht das geht also du bist bei bgc es
probiert
gefühlt also mein erster eindruck war
dass das fühlt sich an als würde ich so
eine kettensäge fahren ja irgendwie so
soll direkt angehen ich meinen husqvarna
macht ja auch rasenmäher und eine
wirklich nur so langsam herum tobt das
hört sich letztlich auch ein bisschen
rasenmäher also endlich die sich geil an
hört man sondern echt ein bisschen gas
geben ja aber ich muss sagen leute
springen auf die bikes und wir sehen uns
jetzt wieder fährleute kasse ungewohnt
guck mal hier leute da muss man auch
sagen weil alexis aufnahmegerät bei sich
hat hat er ein bisschen bessere
audioqualität einfach jetzt der der
auswärts vorteile hat es geht nicht
anders war das auch ich glaube dass 89
zentimeter hoch da sitzt es schon habe
ich gelesen dass von betrieben
ja das glaube ich
oh mein gott wie man hier will ich sitze
passen die aufrechnung das ist ja geil
war das diskutiert wurde hier auch
richtig gut mit das unternehmen ist hier
besser den fall
die schwer jetzt
das ist alles so ein bisschen enger bei
ihr so richtig heftig
mit ach und krach noch an die kupplung
drangekommen beim zu halten
ja ja und hier so hängen
doch überhaupt keine antwort wenn man
wenn man also gar kein feedback dürften
kaum gegangen sind es kann sein dass es
jetzt schon so lange ich weiß es nicht
selbst hält sich mit einer ampel
gegangen und eine bremse ist giftig im
vergleich zu meiner
rainer sound aber auch
danke
dekoriert
blau
zurück
aber genau da vorne rechts
muss man schön unter zu richtig knallen
wie geht und dort macht man einfach du
musst einfach relativ hohen gang nehmen
so dass sie schon so ein bisschen zeit
bis sie zu unterschiedlich
dann immer gut aufs gas geknallt
erfahren
ja schön
schön kurzen
im übrigen macht schon gut wenn es
einmal läuft
aber das gehört dazu
dazu
die quasi schon
die auch schon power so
aber wenn du die mal richtig mist da
kommt dann schon deutlich mehr super auf
jeden fall
das knallen markt kommt
vbr
und da waren jeweils vier
rechner
mehr sein sohn zur welt
ich habe eine aufregung wegen erstmal
geld muss heute wie möglich angehen
wenn ihr reicht von antworten deutlich
dass eine verpflichtung bin
war butterweich dem tor
da bleibt
er war nicht gut
ja
bei solchen vorfällen dann kannst du dem
motorrad von hinten sehen ja gerne
vorbei
gebaut
da muss man sagen der tankanzeige
ein
weil ich hier richtig hochziehen
ja die macht
das gemacht hat komplett dass die
mathematik geht komplett mit ja ja auf
jeden fall dass ich die probe gefahren
bin bin ich direkt an der planung
führten hampel oder so vorne hoch
gegangen also aus versehen weil ich halt
mal so ein bisschen beschleunigung
checken wollte aber die fliegt ja vorne
halt wenn du durch ziehst fliegt die
reform hat echt richtig so
ja
gaddafi ist ein wie die bombe bombe
dafür reicht ist auch immer geil wenn es
motorrad wird was man nicht alle tage
sieht ja
drei punkte wären aber wird gedacht
wirklich ganz so abenteuerlich diese ja
das ist auch abenteuerlich war auch
insgesamt das erste mal gefahren bin ich
fand's super lust ist die sitzposition
und so komplett grad also gewinnt ihr
wirklich denkt hat jürgen stuhl und
besitzt so weit hinten eigentlich dass
aus dem klassiker den man sonst immer so
weit hinten eigentlich ganz viel weiter
vorne sitzen und damit mussten wir
damals so hake serpentinen fahren oder
so richtig enge kurven das ist super
geil mittelding weil das halt so leicht
ist es ganz wichtig die kurve werfen
aber dafür hat auch super hinstellen
wenn du da mal so mit 100 oder so eine
engere kurven mit paar bodenwellen
fährst du das gefühl du fliegst wirklich
darunter oder so oder wenn leute
manchmal auch so in der kurve grüßen ich
habe keinen bock einen einer hand
abzunehmen so während ich in der kurve
bin weil es einfach zu instabil ist das
motorrad war geiles wetter
[Musik]
ich bin gegen die klinge wie ein alter
damit kann zwar kein landregen autobahn
ist schrott damit oder macht einfach
keinen spaß
also ab 130 fängt zu anderen 140 wird
schon echte qual und 160 und ertrag war
eigentlich aber ich bin auch schon zu
180 190 inzwischen fertig schon wo ich
bin echt mit anderen völkern
ja ich bin ich auch immer noch meistens
gehe ich dann immer runter in den ersten
und ziel dann nach oben sozusagen der
autobahn abfahren von der autobahn kann
nicht sein kann gut sein
ja war läuft muss wirklich sagen einfach
verwenden die grund war die fraktionen
also das vibriert sowieso schon
vollkommen anders geht dann gehen wir
ein richtiger rückblick kann bedingt
der sound ist geil ich würde ihn richtig
extrem auch hier hinter dir weil oft so
mit helmen und so weiter hört man sie an
der motorräder nicht so sehr aber weil
die so genannt hat das ist schon echt
ein penetranter sound das sieht immer so
geil aus von hinten weil diese mag ich
finde auf dem motorrad manchmal wissen
aus diese zwölfjähriger hat sie diese
play motoren
ja der ist voll weit weg erst mal dir
viel billiger und genauso lang war wird
wieder unten ist auch einfach ganz
woanders der leute sagt er
also die hat er meistens dann wenn so
hoch drews das permanent wie so ein
ameisenhaufen in den fingern kribbelt
wenn das nicht zu übertrieben ist dann
kommt ja auch richtig panik
kilometerstand und geschwindigkeit und
eine tank leuchte angeschaut
das merkst du ja also ich würde die du
merkst ja auch irgendwann wenn der
begrenzer kommt würde einfach mal
bisschen begrenzer ziehen
man weiß so weiter ist
fachleute und david
alex w
danke meinen sein
bock gemacht haben wir dein motorrad zu
fahren
wir hatten immer wieder lang
genau damit zur ersten motorrad
bewertung in diesem format leute ich bin
richtig halb kommen wir direkt zum
aussäen geiler stormtrooper mäßiger look
allerdings wird auch es wird nicht so
ganz reif das bike also alexander sieht
außerdem playmobil draufsetzen kann dann
stück weit mit geben sechs von zehn fürs
aussehen beschleunigung ist stark 3,75
sekunden von null auf hundert bedingt
durch das geringere gewicht natürlich
und den einzel in der unten aus dem
drehzahlkeller einfach richtig schön
schiebt aber es gibt natürlich noch viel
viel viel mehr bikes die noch schneller
sind deswegen auch hier sechs von zehn
kunden ist es ein bisschen schwierig ich
finde das bike irgendwie schon sehr
frech ich glaube wenn man jetzt ein
krasser supermoto fan ist dann fällt man
das noch mehr zum park punkte fehlen mir
noch aber bei cool das muss ich schon
sieben von zehn gehen ist ein geiles
ding praktikabilität leute da kann man
nicht viele projekte geben das ding hat
keine taschen das hat kein stauraum das
ist es nicht komfortabel dass damit
keine langen touren fahren der verbrauch
ist relativ gering aber da geht nicht
viel drei von zehn preis leistung ist
auch schwierig das ding ist einfach mega
teuer über 10.000 euro basispreis für
das ding das ist einfach ein relativ
einfaches konzept ein zylinder supermoto
aber halt in der größe gibt es aber auch
wieder um fast kein einzelhändler
deswegen auch was besonderes
mehr als vier von zehn würde ich hier
nicht geben der komfort ist absolut
unterirdisch leute man sitzt zwar
relativ entspannt und aufrecht aber das
ding vibriert wirklich bis zum
gehtnichtmehr als wird euch den letzten
cent aus der geldbörse jungen wollen und
das einfach nicht komfortabel kann man
nichts machen besitzt übrigens auch hart
also dass man wissen sollte drei von
zehn mit viel wohlwollen damit kommen
wir insgesamt auf 28 von 60 punkten aber
lasst euch nicht täuschen leute das bike
ist eben sehr beschränkt in seinem
einsatzzweck aber nichtsdestotrotz eine
richtige fan maschine wie man auch an
meiner stimme in dem video gehört hat
nur eben wenn man es über viele
verschiedene kategorien hinweg
vergleicht dann schneidet sie eben nicht
so gut ab aber es ist ein geiles teil
leute ich habe mega spaß gehabt freue
mich aufs nächste video heute ich bin
wieder da macht's gut